it's crisp up punch didn't they sweat
about God he did everything just
definitely got really intense everything
crispy yeah I like Chris's home you know
I was thinking about like which of them
I as a person would be Franklin mmm I
think that I would be friends with
Prince in definitely saying I'm that
yeah well that's nice but we don't
really know actually about you know what
they actually gonna see if I inches no I
have no anybody's I don't know if I be
friends Ashley or my family you know I
mean Jess is dead so I don't know that's
just us keep us well so what happened
she shouldn't they hurt Josh and then
ash went through the door and then Chris
I think she was off on the ground and
then Chris got punched
yeah yeah by a clan looking like this in
that we're still pretty sharp is Jeff
the kitchen of climates yeah it's coming
wastage actually it's just simply never
ending yep looking for things that glow
because I'm what led to just dying and
I'm wondering if that is us or me not
social things
it is this a little so that you can find
but why would that but why would that
kill her
now that's a thing for me to pay
attention to they go blogs better read
that's good just be ketchup don't worry
about it it's probably just ketchup get
to brought em to brunch transfusion
it's camera angles so now I'm gonna make
punched in the face that [ __ ] you got
punched in the face Berg he's just like
well gosh not like what the [ __ ] was
that guy
well I think he's probably just one
borrowed that - it's like like a safety
moment yeah I mean she's like obviously
walking through the house and explain
ketchup everywhere and summer
she's clearly on drugs who does that
soon your ketchup why is it doing this
play which is a weird thing to say since
I'm controlling it but I'm saying why of
all the places would you go out in the
middle of nowhere is everyone tonight
I'm going what trail okay okay yeah
that's one oh you said oh yeah which
makes me think she's probably dead also
but
why did you give that better no I just
chose to mr. option sir but that's not
where the blood was going I just feel
like this there that there's something
you're fine but just stick to it
that's so much blood something we don't
do Oh scarecrow ah finally happened
it's just your art project
breezy I think I say luckily this is
what instructed me Oh what the [ __ ] said
peak what the hell I found a pig's head
that's what the [ __ ]
John what colors that like that I think
that's a death time okay
is it what I think that that was Chris
oh really yeah
did did reboot something I'm not sure I
can rewatch some legends ball one
I can go for it see how many we've
missed oh no are we supposed to be going
up I wouldn't think so but we've missed
these two at the very least this
I care about that this could be peace
blood that's actually a much better
suggestion
yeah that it's pig's blood and not
Ashley's mm-hmm yes I still think it's
job but someone already like oh this is
where were you sell that Death Zone
Jerrica no you don't think so you know I
was thinking though wasn't it it was a
challenge thing where he like they were
like they were where our neighbor
together
oh no that that's really bothering me
peeling off why didn't he look for
someone else in the house best roommate
because Sam Samantha and Emily and
Madame
some way they know that Mike ingests off
by themselves but he could've gone and
found Sam I've been like there was this
[ __ ] guy who punched Ashley the
Thanks yeah but he was like yeah this
chapter is called isolation though is it
yeah now is this the safe place to come
back to or is this different but I've
been coming out this door before
that's what what's that I've is
everything in the house that's a [ __ ]
what maybe it's a loop that door done
making me [ __ ] Cameron once man so
it's the owners Mountain oh oh
that's two people type of [ __ ] and this
is that [ __ ]
hello thank you all for joining us
tonight we're gonna create a little
experiment that [ __ ] now for this
experiment we'll need the cooperation
our two test subjects Joshua
but we're gonna need one more brave
participant to help decide please please
Kings everyone Chris tell Josh right
you'll find another place directly in
front of me all you have to do is choose
who you will say
because if Josh is theirs or why do we
have to go start towards them we don't I
don't know to do no time on this my time
on so we can actually think about this
okay
but I got it let's wait let's wait up
actually we want to save because we like
her because Joshua said [ __ ] but I've
just done anything wrong about Josh and
Josh knows the man you would think I
don't know help maybe not so we go you
don't know what to do I kind of have it
in my head because I think it's Josh
because I have no make it easy killer
like if we choose to kill Josh then what
it is like what if that's the
pre-recorded yeah that's I think I think
that I'm it's it's I think that he's
just outside hope that God would go and
say all the time yeah whoever we are I
think he's expecting us to save actually
probably is expecting us so I think we
possibly want to so join us I think I
want to say Josh I thought were you
think just [ __ ] up really bad and it
just is dead
and now we have to choose between one of
these and I'm going to finish the same
for that
anyone know why we're on the trek to
killing everyone so my best movers we
[ __ ] up so bad I don't know how I
thought it would be much we did a lot of
safety so much safety okay that we have
to do we'll see what your st. Josh well
I don't know what do you think I'm just
thinking that it's probably all right
let's save Josh I'm really no but it's
so wrong
this is really hard I don't know why we
have to choose we just leave oh no I
chose what you choose I don't know okay
I chose Joe he said I'm sorry no we have
to stop this what's that lever
what's that legacy I don't really know
just stop it
which one which one which one I don't
know I just pulled the linkage what we
stopped it no I'm not actually
oh I chose actually
Oh
Oh oh my god [ __ ] up the choice anyway
like I did it the wrong way I thought it
was telling me like bleep Oh bleep uh-oh
that I was like picking which one to
drive it to roids
so I like accidentally saved understand
why we're so bad at this
so right now you're gonna help you all
we need to get off the mountain
discussion yes
we should have told Josh but I try I
guess I made one mistake and I wonder if
it tricked me because Kris said that's
not what I meant
we have to you through we kill two
people whatever well maybe we should
just do that yeah we should say that
there are many I think that'll make it
easier yeah we're gonna do it we're
gonna do it I feel like it's bad for my
conscience
all right let's change our tactic try to
murder all of them yeah but know for
sure
agree with her leave for [ __ ]
Mountain was it was not under that title
it's moving really slowly it's 12 a.m.
right now well it's canceled until dawn
so I think the ideas you have to survive
like five hours
Hey hey buddy what's up now
it's here he's not saying anything you
should spam with is we're doing really
yeah they are yeah
no no
so a genuine question was so the
statement
what is it heartbeat who are you what do
you want
who are you
no you just gettin creepier you creepy a
man
he's getting what could be a little
creepy
he's getting really [ __ ] creepy hell
yeah how did you do that
that's something amazing how is it still
being you beg me for Superman I don't
think that were being self indulgent as
he is freaking me oh yeah so I didn't
even think of that before or is it just
the subconscious in this is the this the
valley and this is his self-conscious
talking to him I have no idea you don't
exist
yeah
good god sir baby I used to enjoy these
conversation is really weird is really
[ __ ] settled